lake mead is just 37 percent full right
now and it could hit its
lowest point ever today bianca holman is
live in our kitchen studio with
more on what this means good morning to
you bianca good morning alex you know we
talk about it all the time
we must conserve our water and of course
again we talked about the reservoir and
that's because the reservoir is going to
reach its lowest level since it was
filled back in the 1930s this is pretty
shocking but again
we are in the midst of a drought so this
is some more information about what
we're experiencing here
if we have a federal shortage in 20 20
22
that would be a decline of about 8 000
acre feet of water
to nevada currently there are no cuts
being made here because we don't use the
entire amount we're allotted from the
lake
however governor steve sisilak is being
proactive to help save water
he signed a bill that gets rid of
non-functional terp
beth moore with the southern nevada
water authority says
it's for grass that never gets stepped
on like medians
sidewalks or grass near sidewalks or
parking lots
we've identified that there are
approximately 5 000 acres of
non-functional turf in the valley
that accounts for about 12 percent of
our water use
and so now california and arizona they
will be impacted more when it comes to
mandatory cuts however
because of complex agreements with
nevada they would be able to use credits
from previous years to offset those cuts
and that means they could still take a
large amount of water
from the reservoir now the biggest users
you may be thinking oh it's the strip
it's the tourists
not quite the strip only use about four
percent of water
it's actually our farmers and of course
again we want to all participate and do
what we can
of course following those watering times
during the summertime when it comes to
watering our grass if you have grass or
changing it over to turf
and conserving our water back to you
guys in the studio